game to a halt as barnes fouls pearl  here  and sometimes it also takes the team  that is fouling out of its offensive  exactly so you just look there when  derek white  tried to throw that shot there there's  21 seconds left on the shot clock  so the kings they're taking a gamble  here but one that probably plays in  their hands unless  jacob can continue to knock down free  throws  [Applause]  and  picture tells the story unfortunately on  that one  jacob wanted one last time  was blustery out there today it was  that headwind is still there apparently  as pirtle is now two of six for  the night and that guarantees you he  will be fouled as soon as the spurs get  the ball  and drew eubanks is probably going to  come back yep he's coming off the  scorers table right now  and